the inferno engulfed dozens of people
minutes before a crowd had gathered to
collect petrol spilled from a truck that
tipped over me in the town of Mora Goro
in eastern Tanzania in this video
the last thing heard is a woman
screaming fire then four minutes later
video that's too graphic for us to show
of people on fire running from the
explosion and piles of charred corpses
this policeman shouts get out of there
but four dozen it was too late what
William a Porteous I'm a psychotic are
easy to cure we are continuing with our
investigation to identify the victims
and we're looking through the property
that has been burned so that we can get
an accurate number of all those affected
many of those who came to collect fuel
were motorcycle taxi drivers for people
struggling to get by a few liters of
free fuel can help feed a family or keep
children in school the collecting it
comes with enormous risk I came here on
a motorcycle and as we approached the
area we found the truck overturned the
driver got off and asked the riders to
get away warning that the vehicle could
catch fire
the riders didn't listen and continue to
Fitch the leaking fuel a man tried to
steal the vehicles battery and that's
when the fire started police say they've
launched an investigation
dozens are in hospital many with severe
burns medics have appealed for blood
donors this communities left in shock
had this rapid and brutal tragedy
Malcolm Webb al-jazeera Nairobi Kenya